what do you think is the hardest
question
or the most difficult issue for an
anarchist society to
try and overcome uh what do you do about
the kids
because if you don't have a state and
kids are basically
under the dominion of their parents how
are you going to resolve
cases which there are no shortage of
when parents are bad actors toward your
their children that is a tough one and
that's a tough one under any scenario
that's the thing
one of the big issues in terms of people
attacking anarchism which is of course
their prerogative
is they'll say well anarchism is bad
because it's going to lead to war i'm
like wait
the system you're advocating doesn't
lead to war so you can't have this kind
of double standard
so this is a criticism like okay you're
not going to have
um you know child protective services
possibly or maybe you would in a private
sense like you have an
apartment complex and you know i don't
know how they would resolve it
the point is it's horrible now like the
foster kid system like many kids
are you know subject to abuse and it's
certainly less than uh
ideal so i that's a good tough question
and i do not have a good answer but i
don't think any system that's been
posited has had a good answer
and that's because typically there's
like
there's an agent within an anarchist
society that kind of opts in
to some of the services which then get
used but in a situation where
the only legal agent
is the bad actor themselves and you have
a dependent
that requires somebody to step in you
have this vacuum which is not being
filled by something
correct yeah that is a nasty situation
yeah and it's it's just it's just not i
it's just nasty in general
i don't know i mean that's yeah that's
an ugly one what about
what about if a country went to war with
another country i know this is in the
second half of one of the
one of the essays that i looked at yeah
uh well first of all it wouldn't be
another country be like an anarchist
area
um but we already see examples of this
in the past which is there's a
this is hilarious which is a criticism
of anarchism that like if you get help
from a state it's not anarchism at all
it's like well if someone mails me food
that doesn't make them the government
they're just someone who's providing a
service right
so as of right now like literally today
i as a private company can hire the us
government to provide security for me
this in no sense makes them my
government any more than hiring a
chauffeur
is the one who's my chauffeur they're
the ones taking orders not giving them
so there are many countries on earth
already this the argument is well if the
u.s went anarchists they'd be invaded
tomorrow
by china well why aren't we invading why
isn't the u.s invading canada by this
logic
why isn't the vatican being invaded by
italy or monaco
uh by france there's many examples of
countries on earth right now
that do not have um any
any military whatsoever and can easily
be overrun uh
so there's sure there are bigger
governments but no one is saying or
i'm certainly not saying that for
anarchism to be considered successful
has to be worldwide
there's no reason why you know if
ireland
was anarchist for thousands of years and
is used as an example historically of
how an anarchist system would work so uh
if you had an invasion
we saw what happened with kuwait let's
pretend kuwait instead of a government
have been an anarchist area
you saw a lot of self-interested nations
with big armies step
in and also it's much harder
to invade and conquer an area where
everyone is armed and trained in using
their weaponry
[Laughter]
but i mean look at afghanistan look at
vietnam i mean this this
argument people say that like well
there's an anarchist area like
you know they'd be conquered immediately
china's not having a fun time conquering
hong kong
so the claim that this is something
that's just done
like with a snap of snapping of fingers
is is nonsensical it's
very very hard to invade and conquer and
very at the very least very expensive
can you see there being an anarchist
state in your lifetime
well no because by definition there
wouldn't be anarchist state but uh
anarchism is a relationship how should i
keep on getting that wrong how should i
refer to it sure just an anarch you
could call it anarchist area or
society but anarchism isn't a location
it's a relationship
right so you and i have an anarchist
relationship neither of us has an
authority over the other
uh if there was a dispute we would not
be calling the state which state would
we call
i mean the possibility of this kind of
international lawsuits
nonsensical and even if you were here or
i were there and
we got drunk and someone got violent
we're still not calling the cops
so you know it's and every country is in
an anarchist relationship with one
another
the example i use in the book is if a
canadian kills an american in mexico
there's no one to call that's above them
right the three nations
have to have some system in place ahead
of time to adjudicate this process
and as we said earlier we can be certain
that they have adjudicated this ahead of
time uh in that
it's not like when that happens they're
like what do we do let's call congress
the process is already in place ahead of
time so whenever someone is in the
process of providing services
they're going to anticipate as much
these things as possible so that their
consumers are
satisfied with it and we see this in a
done in a very haphazard
and ham-fisted way with uh uh
governments right now
okay and you can't see in your lifetime
there being an
area that turns oh i can't oh yeah yeah
oh
it's it's it's not going to be that hard
either it just has to be
even just like uh there's many or
organizations right now that are trying
to basically
uh make things like hap this happen like
seasteading or
or other such uh situations i i think
if people read between the lines there
has been
in recent years yeah or as you would say
yes
a lot of hand-wringing over the
increasing um diligent uh lack of
legitimacy of the state and increasing
um distance between populations and
their governments and they're not
feeling represented
and that's something that's healthy and
from my perspective should be encouraged
as much as possible
although of course members of the
corporate media think this is a
nightmare in disaster
because they go hand in hand with state
power where do you think would be the
most likely anarchist area to rise up
first
oh i have no idea uh in the same way
that marx had said there's no way that
russia's ever gonna go communist and
that's where it had ended up happening
russia
ended up that's where it ended up
happening so
it could be just someone creates a new
physical space
um or someone creates some kind of micro
city somewhere i mean
this is the beauty of markets you don't
know you can't predict where how they
will operate where they'll pop up
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that then press here
for the full unedited episode and don't
forget to subscribe
makes me very happy peace